hey guys my name is Phillip Molina and
this is Erik Voss hey guys uh we are
gonna do a breakdown for the Walking
Dead Season 7 trailer it's one of the
bigger things to come out of Comic Con
this year but so much came out of Comic
Con that we kind of can't cover it all
so we're just gonna knock these things
out as fast as we can this video is just
gonna lay out some of the things that we
noticed as fans of the comics and of the
TV show hopefully we caught some stuff
that you guys didn't yeah and notice how
one of the things that we didn't see
were a lot of the main characters of the
show pretty much anyone who is a
potential victim of negan was shown in
this opening montage but beyond that all
the footage from the new season didn't
really include anyone I think the show's
trying to avoid with careful editing
showing any potential future for anyone
because they don't want to spoil who
might survive and thus who might die
that's it I think there are some clues
in there but we'll get to those as they
go let's just go ahead and get started
we're gonna skip most of that montage
with speed through that and get to the
meat of the trailer
we're Lucille the back shows up I will
let you die out there
everything is or will be okay so we open
this shot of a bunch of people on
horseback these are probably people from
the kingdom headed to the kingdom you
can see that Morgan is walking behind
the whole thing like why can't I get a
horse but it looks like Carol actually
might be on one of those horses if you
remember she's been stabbed and shot a
whole bunch recently so I think it's
nice that they gave her a little bit of
a ride I think that's her peaking out on
the back of one of those horses and
again I think they're headed to the
kingdom when you look closely at this
mailbox and fence on the side of the
frame if you live in Georgia we might
recognize that this shot is taking place
on old Greenville road and Fayetteville
Georgia yeah
now production probably redecorated this
house to make it creepier and more
rundown but either way I'm gonna point
out whether it was there before or not
there's a freaking Cemetery in the yard
for that house what a creepy house I
love it I wonder if they're gonna doing
it in there and in this next shot we see
these chained up walkers and then these
other two guys wearing sweatshirts with
the letters F and s spray painted on
them while the guy wearing the S
sweatshirt takes off this hollowed-out
water cooler off of the walkers head
probably as a safety precaution now one
of the things I think we're gonna see in
this season is the whole societal
structure of the Savior's negan has this
idea of a social high
Turkey where everyone has like a
different job in a different function in
society so I'm wondering if these FNS
labels pertain to these people's job and
whatever their function is within that
social structure and maybe their job is
to assemble this defensive Walker pit
that they might have outside of the
savior compound also on remind people
that they are fond of putting letters on
people and we do know what it means when
you get an x-ray painted on you but yeah
we stopped to see what SNF are then
moving forward it looks like Dwight is
watching over this whole thing by the
way Dwight is all over this trailer so I
feel like Dwight is actually gonna be
one of our main characters here on out
but definitely in season seven if you've
read the comics you know that he's got a
pretty major storyline and this place
that he's in we're pretty sure this is
the sanctuary which is basically an old
factory that they've turned into kind of
a new factory they do all their work
there and by day I mean the Savior's so
this is probably our first look at the
Savior's real compound not that fake
satellite place they had before and then
this next shot Dwight points a gun at
someone who's turned away from us it's
not really clear who it is it might be
Aaron or Eugene this is more that
careful editing they don't want to show
who might have survived vegans kill but
he's saying everything's his or will be
points out what negan's whole philosophy
is that he owns everything or will in
the future I also want to point out
actually take a closer look that vest
that Dwight is wearing that's not his
that's totally Darryl's vest so it could
be maybe from the moment when Dwight
shot Darryl in the shoulder last season
like right after that he took the vest
but I don't know I have a feeling that
does this is actually something we're
gonna see in this season where you know
they're they're holding Darryl captive
or something and Dwight's like you know
what while I'm here I'm gonna take that
vest - I'm a big fan of your look yeah
it's interesting that Dwight keeps
taking Darryl stuff like remember last
season he took his cross boners
motorcycle - and in the comics Darryl
doesn't exist it seems like they took a
lot of the cool stuff about Dwight and
reassigned it to Darryl so now that both
these characters in the show it's like
they're kind of occupying the same role
and there's a struggle for resources
between them who gets to be the cool
character with the crossbow and a
motorcycle now we got to focus on this
one shot right here though where we see
the swing down of the bed remember I
said that there might be some clues that
they accidentally slipped in okay so
let's kind of go frame by frame here
he's swinging down the bat in a moment
we see all this blood shoot up so this
is
and killing whoever receives the rough
end of Lucile but look right behind that
victim that kind of looks like it might
be Dwight standing right behind this
person now if you don't want any
spoilers at all who we think it could be
that's receiving the bat right now I go
ahead and skip ahead to this time but
you compared to the picture that AMC put
out doesn't it kind of look like that
would be Abrahamson cuz Dwight is right
behind him and then if you look over to
the side there's a guy who's wearing
kind of a beanie hoodie combination
which looks like it could be this guy
over here oh and if you've been watching
our Walking Dead videos you know that
I've actually kind of been predicting
since last season that because Abraham's
character arc has pretty much been
completed it would be a really natural
time to kill him off so hmm
also one of the other possible clues
that it might be Abraham came back in
that opening montage at the beginning
the trailer which let's be honest that
kind of felt like the whole thing was an
in memoriam reel at the Oscars Abraham
got a little bit longer of a moment than
the other characters so it seems like
the show is trying to pay him a little
bit more tribute than everyone else
maybe there's also another character who
got a slightly longer section in that
opening montage Glenn now coming out of
that season finale most signs kind of
seem to be pointing to Glenn in our
breakdown that you guys never got to see
you can see we really thought it could
be Glenn the order of the eenie meenie
miney mo shots the audio that kind of
sounds like maybe someone saying Maggie
as they're dying and here some people
are saying that that person the write
could also maybe be Rosita so there's
only one character on that side of
Rosita fly so we haven't totally ruled
Glenn out but in this moment it really
feels like it might be Abraham and that
would make a lot of sense because
there's gonna be another clue later that
we're talking about too so coming back
out of spoilers here keep in mind that
rumor has is that production shot
separate kill scenes here each of these
main characters so if we see some shots
where it looks like negan is lined up
with one person that might be footage
from a different version of that scene
that they share what we're seeing here
might not be exactly what we see in the
season premiere I could see the show
trying to be sneaky and working some of
these alternate shots that aren't
actually part of the real show yeah
anyway moving on there
or rules you earn when you take whatever
he's done to you there's always manna
this section got that epic shot of the
bat and apparently dipped in the
entirety of the amount of blood that
someone has in their body like just
through the hole that he's left in their
head just soaked in blood that is so
much blood but also in this moment I
would also be noticed yeah we see the
shot of negan walking out that could be
in the sanctuary or it could be
somewhere else the framing of the shot
doesn't really make a good beat anywhere
Alexandria or the hilltop but all of his
Savior's are literally kneeling and
respect to him so this just shows that
negan's kind of like a god-like figure
to his savior so you demands this kind
of respect from them and it's
interesting that it seems like it's
gonna be a running theme in this season
it's dealing with some of these old
school social structures and he gets
treated like a king in his society and
then later we're gonna see another
characters literally a king in his
society yeah actually I think is gonna
be the different approaches to governing
like you'll ISM kind of versus like
democracy and Alexandria although it's
not really that one with the microcell
what Rick says that goes damn it Rick I
said stop what but I think that's kind
of the whole point is like all right
well all things considered if we use
history in the way that people have been
run let's see which one works best here
and we know that negan society kind of
works actually but we're now gonna
compare it to different systems of
government yeah and that shot was in the
comics too but moving on to this next
shot of honey aka Sheri they haven't
really revealed what her name is on the
show it's probably gonna be Sheri yeah
and she's same ever he's done to you
there's always cars now remember back
last season she was Dwight's wife but
she might have this relationship with
negan as well look how done up she is
she's wearing makeup she has earrings so
I'm wondering who she's trying to
impress and why she's so made up in the
shot also this scene looks like it could
be part of it another see that we're
gonna see later in the trailer of her
and Dwight in a stairwell like having a
secret conversation we'll come back to
it later but I think it's not weird to
bring up the role that women play in
negan Society it's creepy as hell but
let's look at the next thing
real quick kind of spoilery again about
who might get killed so skip to this
time if you don't want to know
but let's okay examine this version of
this shot it's just another one of these
swing downs from Lucille and in this one
you see those leaves in the upper right
corner ah that feels like it that tree
that's right there all the other trees
are really far away and they're really
dark but here's a lit and it's slightly
to his left which means that again fits
the moment where negan is standing in
front of Abraham so if you're a big fan
of the Jolly ginger giant I don't know
he doesn't look like he's gonna make it
but again we could be so wrong about
this I still feel like it could be him
and Glenn for all we know right now the
Vegas money is on Abraham but it would
explain if Glenn does also die why there
is a walker in that fog that kind of
looks like a beat up Glenn it's probably
not him but it would be a very cheeky
way to be like oh by the way we showed
you dead goin right in the trailer let's
move on we should have made a deal with
them when we could have you should know
there is no door number four this is the
only way
okay so in this next scene we see the
shot of Spencer and remember from last
season he was kind of a gutless
douchebag should we try and make some
kind of deal it seems like he's still
gonna be that way this season we'll see
what happens he might get what's coming
to don't trust him then up next we have
negan probably in Alexandria and he's
hanging out with the Alexandria hottie
Olivia who runs the supplies so I think
this is one of these moments where he's
come to collect what he likes which is
just everything that everyone has and
that's the supply closet lady so he's
gonna warm up to her I assume we're
gonna have long extended romantic scenes
with these two but probably not also
gonna point out those window blinds kind
of look like prison bars so it really
does show like the Alexandria's are
trapped inside the cell with the
scariest guy around Jeffrey Dean Morgan
but I also make it I'm a little scared
of Jeopardy Morgan but the actor yeah
and then quickly in a shot of negan say
so a lot of you have been saying that
this person behind him kind of looks
like Maggie implying that she might
survive negan and Lucille but I don't
know Maggie cut her hair pretty short at
the end of last season and yeah and that
face seems a bit masculine like if you
think that's Maggie mm-hm we have
different views of whether or not that
is an attractive woman at the least they
have a very different nose I'm gonna say
so it could be a savior it could be
someone we haven't met before then we
see quickly Dwight on a motorcycle that
actually might be Daryl's motorcycle
remember he's already wearing the guys
vest he's surrounded by all this blood
and carnage in the middle of the road
it's like flattened like a flattened an
entire body big steamroller just went
over bunch of walkers uh and notice how
he looks more scarred here than he does
in other parts of the trailer so I'm
wonder if we're gonna jump around in
time with Dwight next season we might
see an entire Dwight point-of-view
episode that shows flashbacks I'm
catching up how we got to this point and
what is he looking up at in the shot I
think we're gonna see later in this
trailer but let's move on
ah
coming out of that section we get all
kinds of carnage there's a car that's
like spun around it's up take a look by
the way there's some motorcycles there
but there's just hamish truck that truck
is gonna come up again and again
throughout the trailer I think whoever
driving it feels like a big deal but
there's also some other stuff going on
we get our first shot here actually it's
real quick of Ezekial that's the leader
of the kingdom but we'll get more to him
later he's holding a ladder for some
reason so he's clear got some sort of
plan that he's executing right now he
also looks like you might be saving this
guy in his car he's wearing the armor
that is typical of people from the
kingdom and it's probably even actually
the guy we see in the very next shot
holding this gun and in this next shot
we see a walker falling from an overpass
this might be the scene that I was
talking about earlier where Dwight's
looking up at something if it is that's
a reference to the comics where Jesus
does this to distract way then hogs eat
a freaking Walker which I have no idea
what that means are there's so many
possibilities but also more importantly
probably the walkers look like they're
invading the hilltop which is kind of a
big deal that's the place that Gregory
lives at the really terrible town mayor
that we met last season I really hope he
gets what's coming to him but they'll
tell people aren't so bad that might be
where Maggie needs to go because she's
got a sick baby you remember they had an
ob/gyn luckily so if they're taking on
the hilltop maybe they're gonna hurt
Maggie's chances of her baby being okay
but anyway take a look at Jesus just
beating the hell out of everyone I also
want to point out on the back wall there
you can see that there's now Walker's
but they were probably just normal
people who have been hanging moments
earlier that means negan's probably
playing a role he remember they really
like to hang people it's like their
calling card but anyway let's keep going
I don't know what the hell's going on in
the most wonderful way I am King Ezekiel
welcome to the kingdom so in this
section we see the shot of Jesus jumping
to the back of a moving truck filled
with supplies I'm wondering if this is
another reference to the comics it could
be when Jesus is trying to track the
Savior's back to their compound or when
a different character hides in the back
of a truck to sneak back with the
Savior's we'll see what this could be
yeah and then I do you guys see this
moment with Carol in the auditorium if
you're like me you saw this initially
and you're like oh it's an interview
with the actress just jammed in here in
little two trailers but that's just cuz
it looks so weird she's in an auditorium
but she's almost playing direct to
camera and she just is acting really
weird I don't know what the hell's going
on in the most wonderful way sounds like
she's high she actually might be because
remember again sharp stab and now she's
here for medical help maybe she's on a
bunch of painkillers or maybe she's
doing that act that she does where she's
like I don't know what's going on I'm a
little lady because she's afraid of
these new people and trying to gauge
whether or not they're good but as we
find out in a second she's talking to
Ezekiel and he's a good guy I mean just
look at him we know later he's got a
tiger so how could you be a bad guy have
a tiger when does that ever happen I
also want to point out there is a
possibility that Carolina Zika are gonna
hook up I'm just gonna say it's a
possibility it's the most convoluted
explanation in my head of why that could
happen but I'll say Ezekiel gets a
girlfriend at some point and he's
probably not gonna get the same
girlfriend now so I don't know
my money's on Carol sorry damn hello
darkness my friend
so then we see a quick shot of inside
the sanctuary that's a Savior's compound
and there is electricity those are lit
bulbs and all these people are working
they all have different jobs this to me
looks like a very well developed social
structure the fact they have electricity
and they seem to all know what they're
doing to have their act together this is
a real threat to Alexandria probably the
biggest threat they face to me it
reminds me of North Korea though where
it's like yeah look everybody has a job
and look what the lights are literally
on so everything's probably great here
and those people are probably just as
brain watches of North Korean sorry if
you're watching it's in North Korea but
no one's we're not so because you're not
allowed to oh and then this shot here in
a stairwell with Dwight and sherry slash
honey again it
feels like they're meeting in secret but
again I think that's a lot to do with
negan society and again the role that
women play that you'll see in the show
he's gross and then we see this really
cool shot of negan in his shadow form
knocking at the gates of Alexandria with
Lucille it's such a cool shot to
silhouette I think it might be a
callback to negan's warning in the
season finale so someone knocks on your
door you let us in we own that door but
it's also possibly a reference to the
comics where Nagin's using Lucille to
knock on the gates and he has that
awesome line of little pig little pig
let me in that's when they're doing
their first shakedown of Alexandria then
we have Ezekiel formally introducing
himself hi I'm king Ezekiel it's funny
that not more people do that in the
apocalypse or just like by the way I'm
king Daryl
I'm King Morgan and I'm a princess Carl
I'm just choosing to not be like a high
ranking individual and a woman well
that's fine but I keel is a major
character from the comics and he's gonna
be a big deal we're gonna talk about him
like crazy once these episodes come out
I'm just gonna point out the kingdom
itself is a pretty solid place so in the
comics the kingdom is actually a high
school campus that they've kind of
tricked out but here this is actually
set in Fort McPherson in Atlanta that's
a former army base you can look it up on
Google Earth and see these exact
buildings and courtyards Oh what my
favorite piece of trivia about this
place is that it was recently purchased
by Tyler Perry and the production had to
run it from him would love to see Tyler
Perry show up and a couple rolls this
season
Madea Walker and it looks wonderful it
looks like people are shopping at a
farmers market I think that guys wearing
sunglasses they dole out sunglasses in
the kingdom he's a little picnic basket
there's a little gazebo with class it
seems like a really great place to live
and it probably is gonna get attacked at
some point this season too with these
two new locations the kingdom in the
sanctuary along with Alexandria and the
hilltop it kind of feels like season 7
might be jumping back and forth between
these four different nations within this
new world as they wage war and play
politics with each other kind of like
what we see in Game of Thrones like
maybe you'll see a new opening
in a sequence that just soars over a
giant map showing all of these new
places like the opening credits see good
doesn't look enough already
moving on
Hey Enid made it out of that closet
after all I kind of was hoping that
there would be a whole thing like go eat
it up no she's out of the closet
Congrats there Oh what else we see here
we see the shot of Gregory looking out
of the windows of the hilltop as we see
that glow the fire reflecting I feel
like yeah Gregory is getting what's
coming to him but also we see this bad a
shot of Jesus karate kicking one Walker
at him yes you're the one big egos catch
your foot in his mouth but other than
just that one episode of him with Rick
and Daryl last season we didn't really
get to see a lot of Jesus in action if
you've read the comics you know he's a
real badass fighter so I think this
season will show us more of his moves oh
yeah that fancy uh also speaking of
fancy Shiva
that's Ezekiel's Tiger it's still a
little early so I'm gonna say this TGI
doesn't look amazing but there are
enough people on Twitter that are
talking about the real tiger they got so
I guess it's enough to convince some
people but I think it's gonna get better
as they go what's cool is that they just
put it in the show at all a lot to be
more like oh he'll probably have a
little kitty cat and I'd be like this is
Shiva she's white the tiger or something
but they actually put a freaking tiger
in the show so MC good on you I'll both
see this little one last section of the
trailer
in case you forgot that they existed
it's time Heath having their own axis or
line here there's a couple things to
point out but I'm just gonna say I hope
this is not indicating that there's
gonna be one of those like just tiring
Heath episodes that's just for them it
doesn't touch on anything else I'm not
the biggest fan of those if they do it
I'll live but please don't do it so will
some things we did notice is that check
out how these walkers are coming down to
the sand if you look closely at all
these shots it looks like Tara and Heath
are in some kind of military facility
like maybe they stumble across a place
that might have a lot of weapons or
supplies that they can use and that's
the location where they are you have
that like camo netting and stuff I kind
of also reminds me of what Abraham
stumbled upon last season which did lead
to finding a freaking rocket launcher so
it could be a good thing one other thing
though I want to point out here is take
a look at these walkers walking up here
don't they all look a little like weird
for the walkers were used to remember
the Walker earlier in this trailer is
like missing its jaw and it's like
barely even got an arm bone left and
here they look kind of like bull like
fatty and like big I think this could be
possibly I'm not I mean I like talked
about it too much but just a whole
different kind of Walker that eventually
shows up in the comics I'm saying that
completely fill in Bolinas own
speculation here I could be totally
wrong but there's just something off
about this little mini army of walkers
that all look really similar to me
personally I don't know what you think
yeah it definitely could be the next
step but wrapping up here let's talk
real quick about the song choice that
they use for this trailer it's called
take it all by Royal and the lyrics make
it kind of perfect fit for what these
characters are gonna be going through
this season so let's quickly break them
down
shame all of our characters are
literally going through hell right now
more hell than they've ever gone through
they're losing someone who's near and
dear to their hearts and the next Burton
pile away and so it'd be good so even
though their world is ending the ground
is shaking beneath their feet this is
when heroism comes alive within these
characters it wakes up they're gonna
want vengeance obviously for whoever
neke and killed but also revenge and
started this whole thing because they
killed a lot of [ __ ] people too and so
it's just fury and anger is gonna take
over everybody in the situation and
everybody is a lot larger because as
these next lyrics apply
there's so many more places now the
world has really grown in size as we
have the hilltop and the sanctuary and
the kingdom and Alexandria all colliding
to come together and blood ultimately
dividing then literally these characters
are getting a taste of death by watching
one of their own get butchered by negan
and Lucille also that's what walkers
does get a taste of the little a
mouthful of death yeah but also we hear
this line now I don't want to spoil
anything about the comics but there is a
moment where literally iron meets flesh
with the character if you've read you
know what I'm talking about what I'm not
gonna say anymore and then the chorus of
the song is
and that's literally what negan is
trying to do he feels like he owns
everything everything belongs to him
he's just going to take it by his own
right but everyone's gonna try to keep
everything from him and they're gonna
try to take it back from it yeah Walking
Dead loves to use songs with lyrics so
like fit pretty perfectly they did a lot
of hozier last season I'm actually
interested to see what they do this
season but also in general not just the
music where the frickin story is going
most of all of course finding out who
dies and getting that over with as
quickly as possible hopefully but look
forward to a bunch of breakdowns from us
about Walking Dead as the season comes
out if you're wondering about those
Walking Dead breakdowns that we shot and
released and got blogs they're still
blocked so sorry that you're maybe never
gonna see the hosts but they were fun to
make and that's all we have for this
trailer so make sure to subscribe to new
rockstars and follow us on twitter at
new rock stars for more information
about when our videos are coming out and
if you want to talk to either of us you
can hit me up on Twitter for short
questions about where I think the show
is headed a TA box or you can hit the
Phillip at fimo and you can also hit me
up on Facebook if you have liked longer
stuff you want to talk about is
facebook.com slash T Munoz finally uh
thank you to all our patreon supporters
who have been just ah mah just wonderful
in making it so we can make so many
videos you can tell probably if you
watch this video new follow our channel
a lot of videos came out kind of quickly
and it's all because of our patreon
support so thank you so much if you want
to get involved with that it's
patreon.com slash new rock stars but uh
I think that's it yeah thanks guys see
you next time bye bye